hello i think it's going
steve kaufman here again the linguist on
language it's uh boxing day in canada
the 26th of december
uh i've spent some time up snowshoeing
on cyprus mountain it was a glorious day
it was sunny the snow couldn't have been
whiter i was up there with my wife and
with my
son and grandchildren and we had a great
time
what i want to talk about here
is bilingual texts
why do i want to talk about it because
it was raised by ilya who is one of the
regular
contributors to our
blog at the linguist on language always
has penetrating questions about language
learning and he's also someone who is
designing his own
software for language learning
and it's also something that has been
discussed on this
site that i sometimes go to called how
to learn any language language.com
and
the subject of the discussion
certainly on how to learn any language
was that
one way to learn a language is to get a
hold of a bilingual text book
and that very early on in your language
learning and according to some even at
the very beginning you can start reading
works of literature by reading the
language you are learning which is
sometimes called l2
on the left hand side
and l1 which is your own language or a
language you're very familiar with
on the right-hand side and so you read
ahead in your familiar language and then
you struggle through with the other
language and it was also suggested that
you could be listening to
l2 the target language while reading l1
which is the familiar language so that
you start to hear these words and the
sounds of the language while you are
following along the meaning in in a
language that you are very comfortable
reading
so
and
i guess i'm going to talk about what i
think of this approach and also try to
answer ilya who has raised the very
interesting point that
very often
automatic or computer translation
is more helpful at least to him
than a more literary translation
of something and he cites the example
where at link we have the power of the
linguist which is a very simple story
for beginners we have it in four or five
languages and he finds the computer
generated translation more helpful to
his language learning and he's a
beginner in spanish in this case
more helpful than um the actual man-made
translation so where do i what do i
think of all of this
let's begin by saying that reading in my
opinion is extremely important to
language learning now yes there are
people in the bazaar in morocco or you
know all kinds of people who become
quite fluent in another language and
never learn to read and there are many
people who when faced with languages
like japanese or chinese with very
difficult writing systems simply learn
to speak and they do it quite well so
yeah you can learn without reading but
if you learn to read you will learn
faster you will learn more words you
will have an easier time
um and reading is is um you know i i've
had a i bought a book over over
christmas called um
the called proust and the squid and it's
written by uh marianne wolfe and it
talks about reading and how we develop
the ability to read and how this
represents something very very new for
our brains
and she points out how proust
says famous french writer that when we
read we have that tremendous opportunity
to communicate with people from another
time and place even sitting in the
solitude of our own room
and so reading does wonderful things
and it is certainly very very
useful for language learning
and i would add reading and listening
because now we have this tremendous
capability with
mp3 files and the manipulation of sound
files that we can we can listen to
anything we want wherever we want
so reading and listening i have said it
many times and and when i saw stephen
krashem uh explain this whole concept of
meaningful input i said wow that's
exactly the way i feel about language
learning so he is both an inspiration to
me and also someone who has sort of
confirmed what i have learned
so much on my own and i've got to check
the time here how much time have i used
up okay
uh so
i believe that reading bilingual books
is distracting
it's something i do occasionally if i do
not certainly before i had link before i
had the opportunity to look up words
uh
on the internet save the words to a
database do all the things that we do in
link
yes i in my russian at a certain point
did take along some bilingual books if i
was traveling somewhere
i didn't have access to the computer i
would read along a little bit in english
a little bit in in russian
i don't like doing it because it's
distracting because you tend to leave
the russian in my case if i'm learning
russian you go off to the english
you forget a little bit of what you saw
there you come back you're still
struggling with the russian there are
still words that you don't know what
they mean
as you get better you then go
and look at the english even when you
don't need to
you'd be better off just to look up the
few words that you need
so my preference is for reading
difficult text on the computer with
access to an online dictionary and
preferably in an environment like link
where you can capture the words and then
review them later on reviewing words
that you have
saved from a text
that you have identified as words that
you need to learn reviewing these words
in a variety of ways is very helpful and
useful
even though
you will probably pick up most of your
words through your extensive reading
but the review of the words even if it's
not thorough even if it isn't every word
that you review it forces you to look at
the more closely it is in my view very
useful in the whole process of acquiring
vocabulary so i'm not a fan of bilingual
texts i tried it in different ways i
have also tried listening to
russian while reading english reading
anna karenina for example
one thing i will agree with ilya if i'm
reading in russian and i have trouble
with a paragraph
i prefer to take that paragraph and put
it onto a computer translation site and
get the translation and pick through and
so now i've got a sense of that
paragraph i go back and i save the words
that i need but i don't want to
systematically be reading every
paragraph
in
the native language or a familiar
language and i don't want to be tempted
to go there all the time and that's the
trouble with notes as well all the
explanatory notes or words
that they identify as the words that you
need to look up all of this to me is
distracting i prefer to fight my way
through a text words that i don't know i
click on them i look them up and they go
on my list
so
i was surprised that ilya found the um
the computer-generated translation more
helpful for the power of the linguist
which is a simple text
i found when i tried the power of the
linguist in
italian and japanese even though i speak
both languages when i put them onto the
computer generated translation i got
junk bag not at all helpful i have found
that computer generated translation
works very well for russian that may
have something to do with the people who
who obviously do the software so
where do i stand on this bilingual text
it's a matter of taste some people like
them and generated a lot of interest at
how to learn any language i'm not a fan
i've tried it i find it distracting i
prefer to get into
the language that i'm learning stay in
that environment try to read it listen
to it
and i only leave that language when i
know that i need help so i decided i
need to learn look up that word i
decided that i have trouble with this
paragraph and i go outside and get help
i should add that
even if you don't 100
understand the paragraph it really
doesn't matter look up the words you
looked up some words you still don't
understand it i just plow on
and eventually two months later i'll
read that text again and i will
understand it
so
uh there are lots of bilingual texts
available it's a little more difficult
to find them
uh that's another thing it's it's much
easier to find uh text which are not
bilingual
and there is so much help now on the
internet that i personally think that's
the way to go so ilya that's an answer
to you and uh to your question and i
look forward to hearing uh you know
people's opinion on this
and i'm also gonna answer another of
elia's questions which has to do with
uh how to use this sort of recording of
word lists from link but i'll deal that
with that in a separate podcast and
webcast thank you very much for
listening come and visit us at
lingq.com link
or the linguistic language of course
which is the linguist.blogs.com
thank you for listening